[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing harry potter the forbidden
forest
the resurrection stone and albus
dumbledore the resurrection stone is of
course one of the fabled
deathly hallows stemming from the tale
of the three brothers
antioch cadmus and ignotus the brothers
were all members of the famous peverell
family
the plot surrounds the three wizard
brothers and their ability to cheat
death
for a short period of time after
conquering death a personification of
death
under the guise of congratulating them
awarded them with three gifts
the elder wand the resurrection stone
and the invisibility cloak
long story short each brother chose one
of the gifts that death had presented
them
ignotus the youngest chose the
invisibility cloak
cadmus the middle brother chose the
resurrection stone
and antioch the eldest chose the elder
wand
from the tale of the three brothers then
the second brother who was an arrogant
man
decided that he wanted to humiliate
death still further and asked for the
power to recall others from death
so death picked up a stone from the
riverbank and gave it to the second
brother
and told him that the stone would have
the power to bring back the dead
so naturally when harry eventually comes
into possession of the stone
he uses it to see the shades of loved
ones that he has since lost
they were neither ghost nor truly flesh
he could see that
they resembled most closely the riddle
that escaped from the diary so long ago
and he had been memory made nearly solid
less substantial than living bodies
but much more than ghosts they moved
toward him
and on each face there was the same
loving smile james was exactly the same
height as harry
he was wearing the clothes in which he
had died and his hair was untidy and
ruffled
and his glasses were a little lopsided
like mr weasley's
sirius was tall and handsome and younger
by far than harry had seen him in life
he loped with an easy grace his hands in
his pockets and a grin on his face
lupin was younger too and much less
shabby and his hair was thicker and
darker
he looked happy to be back in this
familiar place the scene of so many
adolescent wanderings
lily's smile was widest of all she
pushed her long hair back as she drew
closer to him
and her green eyes so like his searched
his face hungrily
as though she would never be able to
look at him enough james
sirius lupin and lily were all massively
important in harry's life
so it's no surprise that they showed up
however to me it always felt a little
bit like one person was missing
a certain hogwarts headmaster why wasn't
dumbledore there
he was hugely influential in harry's
life since childhood
and the two shared a unique connection
so what's the deal
the truth is that though dumbledore was
once a paternal figure for harry
a source of comfort and what harry
perceived as love things changed during
voldemort's resurgence to power
when harry learned of dumbledore's true
motivations their relationship suffered
as a result
dumbledore's number one priority was
never to save harry's life
and it never would have been his primary
goal was to protect the greater
whistling world
and second to that goal dumbledore's
objective was to defeat lord voldemort
yes damodar had affection for harry but
he wasn't top priority
and that meant that saving his life
wasn't top priority either
especially if it meant that he could
more effectively achieve his other goals
the following passage from the deathly
hallows perfectly depicts harry's
attitude toward dumbledore after the
truth was revealed about the deceased
headmaster
i don't know who he loved hermione but
it was never me this isn't love
the mess he's left me in he shared a
damn sight more of what he was really
thinking
with gallop grindelwald than he ever
shared with me harry felt insignificant
and it wasn't until harry had the
opportunity to meet dumbledore at king's
cross station
that his feelings toward dumbledore
shifted once more however while they
were able to pick up the pieces somewhat
their connection definitely wasn't what
it once was dumbledore had hidden so
much from harry
and had used him like a puppet even if
his motivations were pure
he used harry plain and simple he left
him in the dark
and this meant that their relationship
suffered as a consequence the
resurrection stone only presents you
with the shades of those that represent
selfless unconditional love and despite
dumbledore's affection for harry
their relationship was never anywhere
near this level james
lilly remus and sirius all cared for
harry more than anything
and would easily prioritize his life
over any other objective or goal
and this is where dumbledore differed
dumbledore was a great man with
huge goals but it would be silly to say
that his love for harry
was entirely selfless because it wasn't
and that's why dumbledore never showed
up
in a forbidden forest and that's it for
this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you